certaines images se suivent et se
ressemblent quelque peu je connais votre
finesse d'esprit votre capacité de
travail votre attachement à l'état je le
disais il ya un instant votre amour de
la france en avril 2014 bernard
cazeneuve succéder à manuel valls place
beauvau alors que ce dernier prenait la
tête du gouvernement
un an plus tôt ce fidèle de françois
hollande en mars 2013 arrivés à la hâte
à bercy au budget pour remplacer jérôme
cahuzac
empêtré dans ses affaires de fraude
fiscale mais c'est bien au ministère de
l'intérieur qu'il prend de l'envergure
il a dû gérer les attentats les plus
meurtriers commis sur le territoire
français si beaucoup reconnaissent à
gauche comme à droite sa maîtrise et son
professionnalisme
d'autres ne pardonne pas ce mot sauvages
ont prononcé pour désigner les auteurs
de l' attaque de viry-châtillon contre
des policiers
ils ont été confrontés une bande de
sauvageons qui ont agi avec lâcheté une
parole qui avait conduit fait rare les
gendarmes et les policiers à manifester
cet avocat de formation s'est gardée
secrète les confidences c'est qui lui
vaut un surnom le silencieux
une discrétion cher à françois hollande
qu'il soutient sans faille malgré les
soubresauts de la mandature cinq mois à
matignon
voilà la dernière mission que lui a
confié le chef de l'état impossible de
refuser pour l'élève modèle du
quinquennat